[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
échos votre magazine d'actualités
économiques sur saint quentin en
yvelines tout de suite le sommaire de
cette édition deuxième édition du sky
emploi en piste ce job dating
rassemblant près de 160 entreprises
s'est tenue le 4 avril dernier au
vélodrome nationale il a permis à de
nombreux participants de décrocher un
emploi ou de signer un contrat en
alternance l'innovation technologique au
service de la santé c'est le dossier de
cette émission nous nous sommes rendus
au siège de baxter france à guyancourt
pour découvrir leurs innovations sur la
télésurveillance des dialyse à domicile
découverte aussi des technologies de
blue line et à destinés aux personnes
âgées
enfin retour sur l'actualité économique
dans le département notamment sur le
rachat du laboratoire
emc par l'entreprise emitech et sur les
résultats du premier semestre de sodexo
près de 3000 personnes se sont rendues
au salon sky emploi en piste le 4 avril
dernier au vélodrome nationale une
journée consacrée à l'emploi 160
entreprises présentes et cinq mille
offres de postes proposés
un événement organisé pour la seconde
fois par saint quentin en yvelines
objectif faciliter le recrutement et la
recherche d'emploi le récit de cette
deuxième édition sur des images de
mélanie poquet ils sont sur la piste
d'un travail ou à la recherche du bon
profil demandeurs d'emploi et recruteurs
se sont retrouvés pour le sky emploi
jeudi 4 avril au vélodrome national au
milieu de la piste cinq mille offres
d'emploi à pourvoir
là clairement non l'advd profil de poste
qu'on va pouvoir recruter dans
l'immédiat alors que nos annonces on
n'avait pas forcément de candidats qui
postulent et sur ces annonces à j'ai eu
à choisir parmi 50 candidats donc
cinquante candidats quand vous êtes une
société de 12 personnes
c'est quelque chose d'assez très
précieux nous sommes dans un grand
bassin où il ya énormément l'entreprise
donc si je pense que c'est leur
rendez-vous qu'il fallait absolument pas
rater
quelles compétences vous mettez en avant
dans vos entretiens bas que j'ai
travaillé pendant
cinq ans en suisse dans des assurances
et dans d autres groupes
au total 160 entreprises ont participé à
cette deuxième édition tous les secteurs
économiques de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
représenter 3000 visiteurs et 2500
entretien à la clé la qualité des
visiteurs à la qualité des cv moi j'ai
fait le tour là entre 14h et 18h je peux
vous dire que j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
de contrats phares pré-contrat signé
cette journée l'occasion aussi de lancer
la plateforme sky emploi un nouvel outil
pour assembler les offres d'emploi sur
les douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
la notion de jeu va voir entrer mon
profil on va me proposer les offres le
plus adéquat à mon profil de leur côté
des entreprises créé leur profil et
mettent en ligne leurs offres pour vous
inscrire rendez vous sur le site sky
emploi.fr
on ouvre notre dossier thématique sur
les technologies au service de la santé
merck leo pharma bertin de nombreuses
entreprises pharmaceutiques sont
implantés sur saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas aussi du groupe américain
baxter spécialisé notamment dans les
dispositifs de dialyse des solutions
pour filtrer le sang des personnes dont
les reins ne fonctionnent plus avec des
innovations dans ces domaines
rencontre avec guillaume lefebvre
directeur marketing chez baxter france
sur des images de mes amis poké c'est un
géant mondial du secteur pharmaceutique
le groupe américain baxter le siège
social de sa filiale française est
installée historiquement sur saint
quentin en yvelines
d'abord à maurepas et puis ensuite à à
guyancourt depuis 2015 et nous sommes
avec guillaume lefebvre bonjour bonjour
donc vous êtes directeur marketing
thérapie rénale chez baxter france
oui alors l'année dernière vous avez
lancé en france une solution assez
innovante la plateforme connectée pour
la télésurveillance de la dia la dialyse
péritonéale appelé chez ressources
oui notamment avec cet outil là qu'on
voit ici devant nous alors c'est un
outil destiné aux personnes souffrant
d'insuffisance rénale
comment ça fonctionne alors on fait ça
fonctionne avec un système donc qu'on
appelle le home chase qui est un système
de dialyse péritonéale automatisés
qui permet aux patients de se traiter à
domicile durant la nuit avec en fait un
cycle heures et des poches
alors comment ça se passe en fait le
patient en fait il prépare son cycle
heures donc ils installent
il est d'abord formée par une équipe
infirmière au niveau de ce centre
hospitalier dont il dépend et ensuite il
installe son matériel au domicile
et puis il pratique sa séance de dialyse
la nuit lorsqu'il dort et du coup c'est
un outil qui permet de rendre le patient
finalement indépendante c'est ça oui le
but de la delivery tonia qui se déroule
quasiment exclusivement au dos messieurs
c'est vraiment l'indépendance et
l'autonomie du patient et donc nous
avons développé le système chez
ressources pour justement favoriser
encore plus à d'autres mines autonomie
des patients alors en quoi c'est
finalement le service c'est c'est de la
technologie au service de la santé c'est
ça exactement c'est vraiment la
technologie au service de la santé comme
vous le dites c'est de permettre en fait
de rapprocher encore plus le patient qui
est à son domicile de son équipe
soignante au quotidien comment ça se
passe finalement c'est quoi ces les
médecins pour avoir en direct se
connaître l'état du patient pendant ce
sa dialyse
alors c'est pas l'état du patient qu'ils
vont connaître en fait le système
fonctionne durant la nuit le patient
utilise son site leur comme il a
l'habitude de l'utiliser il dort comme
d'habitude et le matin lorsqu'il se
réveille son traitement se termine et
les données présentes à l'intérieur du
cycle heures qui correspondent à la
prescription élaboré par le médecin sont
envoyés directement sur le système sur
la plate forme qu'on appelle chez
ressources et les équipes soignantes au
niveau de l'établissement de santé ont
accès à ces données c'est de la
télésurveillance et les savoisiens avec
ce qu'on voit de plus en plus en ce
moment dans le secteur de la santé en
france c'est la télémédecine 6 à céline
oui c'est une forme de télémédecine en
fait si la télésurveillance qui permet
justement de rapprocher comme je vous le
disais le patient de son équipe
soignante
c'est quoi l'objectif finalement
l'objectif c'est d'assurer encore plus
de sécurité on va dire au domicile des
patients pour les équipes soignantes
or cette solution a été développée aux
états unis vous vous avez été chargé de
la déployer en france depuis je le
rappelle depuis l'an dernier
le premier centre hospitalier à avoir
utilisé cette solution c'est le centre
de corbeil essonnes oui c'est bien cela
comment vous vous en avez fait la
promotion justement de cet outil
le centre hospitalier corbeil essonnes
est un centre expert en dialyse
péritonéale avec une équipe médicale et
paramédicale référente et donc il était
logique en fait de se tourner vers un
centre hospitalier experts qui étaient
moteur et qui souhaitait justement
bénéficier de ce type d'innovation
comment a été accueilli ce type de
solution on est un an après le
déploiement notamment dans ce centre
quel retour vous avez quel premier bilan
vous pouvez faire alors le premier bilan
relativement positif on va dire on a
aujourd'hui une centaine de patients qui
sont connectés sur ce système là et
depuis donc un en fait on apprend au fur
et à mesure des retours qui nous sont
faits par les équipes soignantes les
bénéfices en fait ils en retirent au
quotidien alors juste une question un
peu plus globale je rappelle que vous
vous vous occupez eux uniquement delà du
traitement au niveau rénal
oui la stratégie qu'adopte baxter france
sur cette thématique là pour innover
quelle est elle alors ce n'est pas de
l'innovation pour dire de faire
d'innovation baxter réfléchit à une
stratégie d'innovation qui sont en
rapport avec des besoins exprimés par
les équipes soignantes et par les
patients donc vous êtes en échange
quasi-quotidiens je suppose
avec les centres hospitaliers oui avec
les centres hospitaliers oui en fait et
on fera progresser on va dire cette
cette technologie là en fonction des
remontées qui ne seront faites de part
le monde au niveau 2 au niveau de ses
ressources
votre vision sur la technologie au
service de la santé
comment doit se positionner justement la
technologie par rapport à la santé elle
doit se positionner comme je vous le
disais sur un bénéfice qui doit vraiment
être ressenti par les équipes soignantes
et par les patients on doit pas dire de
faire la promotion d'une technologie ou
d'une autre uniquement pour faire la
promotion de technologies
un dernier mot c'est sur les projets de
demain vous êtes en train de me dire
qu'il ya des échanges avec les
personnels des professionnels de santé
des centres hospitaliers justement sur
quel projet vous réfléchissez en ce
moment par rapport à la thérapie rénale
toujours des projets dont on va dire
dans l'amélioration de chez ressources
on fera progresser comme je vous disais
la plateforme chars source au fur et à
mesure des besoins remontée parler
parler parler parler centre hospitalier
c'est prématuré pour en parler oui c'est
un petit peu prématuré pour en parler
bio le faire merci beaucoup merci je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur
marketing thérapie rénale chez baxter
france c'est une activité qui pourrait
générer 130 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en france la silver economy
appelé aussi économie des seniors ce
secteur lance aussi des innovations au
service de la santé des personnes âgées
c'est le cas notamment de l'entreprise
blue line et a installé à elancourt
reportage le 11 novembre 2018 alain
tavernier est victime d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral
pendant sa convalescence il reste à son
domicile s'occupe en faisant des
maquettes
par sécurité il s'abonne au bouton
d'appel et détection de chute de blue
line est à relier à une plateforme
d'appels japy dessus il ya une petite
lampe rouge qui s'allume
donc voilà et à ce moment là moi
j'entends qu'effectivement c'est pris en
compte
tout fonctionne bien il n'y a pas de
problème merci beaucoup au revoir quand
je suis revenu à la maison mes enfants
ne voulaient pas que je reste seule
comme ma femme faisait des courses ou
avec ses activités me laisser seul donc
d'une part pour moi me rassurer elle a
rassuré elle aussi directeur du
développement chez blue line et à xavier
corbin vient faire un bilan avec le
client comme alain tavernier près de
28000 personnes sont abonnés à ce
service d'accompagnement de réconfort et
d'assistance c'est un dispositif qui
s'adresse effectivement un public qui
risque de chuter ou qui a déjà chuté
mais pas uniquement il faut bien voir
que sur l'ensemble des appels que l'on
reçoit dans 90% des cas on va répondre à
des à des demandes qui sont des demandes
de la vie quotidienne qui n'ont aucun
caractère critique aucun caractère
urgent la technologie est également très
importante pour la sécurisation du
transfert des informations et le
traitement de chaque situation au siège
de blue line et à elancourt des
opératrices sont chargés de prendre les
appels 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
cette entreprise emploie aujourd'hui
près de 4
vingt collaborateurs son activité
proposer des solutions pour les
personnes dépendantes
on voit régulièrement apparaître de
nouvelles solutions de nouveaux objets
je dirais presque parfois de nouveaux
gadgets qui sont plus ou moins
intéressants pour nos marchés
donc pour nous il est vraiment très
important de choisir les bons produits
de développer les bons produits
parce que la technologie est en fait
qu'un moyen de délivrer un service ou de
délivre une solution autre technologie
proposée le bracelet blue garde destinée
aux personnes atteintes d'alzheimer
on va l'équipe et de ce bracelet du blue
garde et elle va pouvoir se déplacer à
son gré le bracelet sa fonction c'est de
vérifier en permanence que la personne
est bien dans un périmètre dans une zone
de vie prédéfinis et si elle venait à
s'éloigner trop et à sortir de cette
zone de vie automatiquement nous
recevrions une alerte sur nos
plateformes sahara la société a lancé
aussi un nouveau produit pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
un dispositif pour leur permettre de
jouer à des jeux vidéo
on passe tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref installé à montigny
le bretonneux et mitec a racheté le 28
mars dernier le laboratoire
emc basée à achères spécialisé dans la
certification industrielle des mitec
veut élargir son activité sur les tests
de moteurs automobiles et de transport
aérien avec une réflexion sur les
système hybride hydrogène et électriques
cette acquisition permet au groupe
d'augmenter son chiffre d'affaires et de
tabler sur 55 millions d'euros en 2019
une bonne santé économique pour le géant
de la restauration collective sodexo
installé sur billancourt enregistre un
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 11
milliards d'euros au premier semestre
2018 2019 soit une croissance de 3,1
pour cent un résultat au dessus des
prévisions des journalistes nationaux et
internationaux ont parcouru le cluster
paris saclay ils ont notamment visité le
ski tubes à guyancourt en rencontres
avec les créateurs des start-up incubés
découverte des services proposés par
l'agglomération dans le cadre du
développement économique
l'occasion aussi de montrer la
complémentarité entre saint quentin en
yvelines versailles grand parc et la
communauté d'agglomération de paris
saclay et pour terminer la banque
postale ouvre un centre d'affaires
destiné aux entreprises à montigny le
bretonneux
c'est le premier de ce type dans les
yvelines accompagnement des sociétés
conseil aux pme et eti offre de services
financiers et bancaires la banque
postale propose une gamme de solutions
tout au long du cycle de vie des
entreprises c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]